en pleine crise des banlieues jacques
chirac avait annoncé la création d'un
service civil volontaire pour mieux
aider les jeunes en difficulté ce projet
fait partie de la loi sur l'égalité des
chances et a pour but de donner à des
filles et des garçons sur la base du
volontariat une ouverture vers des
milieux associatifs une mission
d'intérêt général voyez l'exemple de ce
nouveau ces nouveaux engagés par
l'association unis cité il travaillera
auprès de petits frères des pauvres mal
réel nos virginie travers dans le
quartier des mordacq à champigny sur
marne les après-midis peuvent être
triste et désoeuvrés
mais ces jeunes ont rendez vous avec un
club du 3e âge ils sont volontaires
auprès de l'association des petits
frères des pauvres ils rencontrent les
habitants du quartier pour repérer les
personnes âgées isolées se sont guère
sociale ni citer de volontariat
gouvernement que l'eau certes
villenouvelle d'adopter rebiffe 50 mais
dès 2007 avec dj acteurs associatifs et
les eaux dans les positives et
ressemblances et la public dans ce cadre
jeunes pourront par exemple gré 16
pompiers blanche se dissipa les dalles à
déceler ce qui comporte souvent déjà
saturés titre soit de la seconde fois
elle pas sur le temps produits les chefs
de vente parce qu'ils ne sont pas je
vois un cône est très positif donc il
fera suisse civile volant pour créer une
vision que ne vienne nature et en club
pour leur souhaiter des conditions soit
un statut pour le volontaire et une
meilleure articulation avec la scolarité
et l'emploi notre équipe elle continue
de prospecter est convaincu d'avoir fait
le bon choix
au départ on est toujours réticents ont
dit à quoi ça va nous servir
je préfère travailler et tout ça et puis
quand on moncontour à l'envers du décor
dans les surpris on envie de rester ce
service civil sera destiné en priorité
aux jeunes en difficulté décevant pour
les députés ps où l'udf au nom du
brassage culturel et social je le
souhaitais obligatoire pour tous